Owen and Mark thanks for joining
spectator TV Owen you write the cover
piece for this week's magazine about the
possibility of a so-called peace deal in
Ukraine tell us about recent reports
that suggest that something could be in
the works uh well first and foremost um
let's be very clear we're not talking
about a peace deal we're talking about a
ceasefire and those are actually two
very really important things um I think
uh a ceasefire is something that Putin
has reportedly and uh uh I know
personally the reporters that worked on
this for the New York Times who reported
it on 23rd of December and they have
very good sources and uh uh their
information is that there have been
unofficial backchannel feelers from the
Kremlin to uh senior officials in
Washington to discuss the possibility of
a ceasefire ceasefire not necessarily a
peace deal but a ceasefire um
essentially freezing the conflict along
the line of control and uh I find that
uh pretty plausible actually because um
that kind of deal um that kind of
Arrangement that kind of ceasefire
allows Putin to sort of lock in a
situation on the ground that he hopes is
going to become a de facto eventual
partition of Ukraine um but the point of
my piece this week is um that although
Putin putting out peace feelers or
wanting to talk is not necessarily news
what's really news is that I think uh
what US policy policy makers are
starting to realize is is that um one
essential ingredient of any kind of
eventual ceasefire or post-war
Arrangement or end game orever you like
to call it is
essentially dividing Ukraine and
allowing Putin to keep the part that
he's already occupied and that comes
with
enormous uh moral hazard and practical
problems Mark do you agree with Owen's
characterization of Putin's thinking
after the Christmas assault on Ukraine
can we take these calls
seriously we can because it's for
entirely pragmatic reasons look on the
one hand Putin clearly has a a wider
goal of actually wanting to essentially
subordinate Ukraine remove it from being
part of as he sees it the West's sphere
of influence and bring it back into his
but essentially Putin is also deeply
pragmatic he's aware that this is an
exceedingly expensive politically and
economically War for himself
and although this coming year is
unfortunately looking quite good for the
Russians they have an advantage in terms
of ammunition the ukrainians are
probably going to have to spend the year
essentially rebuilding after their
rather unsuccessful counter offensive
and so forth once you start getting into
2025 and Beyond there's actually some
real risks for the Russians so I can see
Putin thinking well this is a good time
precisely to regard this as as something
as a high Watermark of of of Russian uh
occupation let's try and freeze it now
through the the medium of a ceasefire if
things change dramatically
then I can I can always break the
ceasefire it's not as though Putin
regards himself as being sort of bound
by these kind of agreements but on the
other hand it also poses a great dilemma
for the West because let's be perfectly
honest not only are there many countries
in the west that would frankly rather
not be spending what it costs to support
Ukraine but also particularly in
Washington there is a a
growing almost Terror of what might
happen where Donald Trump to win the
presidency and certainly for some people
within the blob I mean I'm encountering
it in my own conversations with with
officials there is that sense of we
can't let this war roll on until it
becomes Donald Trump's playground we
actually have to reach some kind of of a
settlement before that point which makes
them really quite vulnerable to this
kind of suasion from Moscow oh and I
want to pull up the cover image here
because I I think it makes the point
really well that when we talk about a
peace deal some kind of deal a ceasefire
uh these words don't necessarily reflect
reality H it has been a big talking
point from the beginning of this
conflict that agreeing to some sort of
peace deal would legitimize Putin's
Terror and what he's done but there's
also a bigger question for ukrainians
about whether or not it just gives him
more time to regroup and come back even
stronger when we talk about all of these
options whatever name we put on them are
we really talking about a safer World
particularly for
Ukraine uh yeah I think that that's
absolutely right I mean as as uh as Mark
completely correctly has said and has
argued for many years the the the key
feature of the Putin regime has always
been this absolutely ruthless uh um
pragmatism and the fact that they
constantly adapt to situations and uh
it's very hard to actually read any kind
of grand strategy or or let me put it
differently I mean although a grand
strategy may exist um uh there in in the
Kremlin in Putin's mind there are
usually several such Grand strategies
running in parallel and actually they
just sort of chop and change between
them all the time we've seen that time
and time again you know Over Georgia
over Syria um over over cremia and so on
they you know they they they basically
Putin will take whatever he can get um
the the the the the the problem is um
the really fundamental difficulty is
that a Forever War does not favor
Ukraine So currently there's a major
disconnect between the official position
of uh zilinski and his inner team which
is that we need to fight on the end we
need to persuade the West to give her
the weapons um that we need to fight the
war although in parenthesis it's not
really clear having had the weapons they
have what further escalation is going to
be required to actually achieve the goal
of returning 1991 borders I mean that's
a lot of of equipment but there's a
fundamental disconnect between that
zinsky position that we need to going
keep fighting until Russia is defeated
and the actual future of Ukraine because
actually although the war as marus said
is expensive uh for Russia it's still um
building up its uh it's its military
capabilities it's getting stronger I
would say not weaker um over time and
meanwhile Ukraine is losing its
main asset um tragically which is its
people and the Ukraine faces the a
terrible shortage of uh of men to
recruit for the front lines and we
already see some some fractures
appearing in Ukrainian Society so in a
nutshell you have a contradiction and a
problem because actually a long endless
war does not favor Ukraine it probably
favors Russia uh and at the same time
the longer the war goes on the longer
Ukraine has to wait to actually
reconstruct itself reform itself and
sail off into its bright European future
none of that can happen until a
ceasefire happens or until the conflict
is somehow resolved Mark what do you
make of those comments that a longer war
is more difficult for Ukraine How likely
is it that Ukraine could win back some
of that remaining land and do you think
the Ukrainian people are ready to accept
some kind of deal that doesn't include
all of that land being returned when
asked the straightforward up and down
question of should we fight on until we
have achieved victory victory being
defined in terms of regaining all the
occupied territories a majority a very
clear majority of ukrainians still say
yes but in some ways that's misleading
because that is if nothing else an
appeal to patriotism people know what
the quote unquote right answer is what's
interesting is I know there's been focus
group work talking to trying to talk to
ukrainians about particular objectives
and essentially what would you think is
an acceptable cost in TS of lives and
Owen is absolutely right I mean although
the Russians have lost a lot more men
proportionate to population Ukraine is
suffering greater than the Russians so
you know what do you think needs to be
spent and you know when we look at for
example Crimea a lot of ukrainians
frankly are probably not thinking that
it's worth the likely cost of regaining
this peninsula many of whose inhabitants
especially now that there's been about a
million Russian colonists
currently you know many of whose
inhabitants therefore actually want to
be Russian rather than Ukrainian I
remember once talking to a Ukrainian
interior Minister official fairly senior
who was concerned that basically he said
Crimea could be our Northern irand so I
mean for all these reasons you know one
has to go beyond that overall sort of
current determination to regain all the
territory I think that certainly in the
west but also amongst quite a few
figures within Kev there is a quiet
awareness that someday some deal will be
struck the problems are two one is no
one wants to say so publicly for fear of
being pillared especially so long as
zalinsky himself is so fervently
committed to a full maximalist kind of
Victory but the second thing is in some
ways no one wants to show their hand
before any
negotiations the sense being if you
moress admit that you for example might
not want Crimea then in a way the
Russians would take as gred well we've
got crime
what else can we get so this is the
trouble at the moment in a way it is
waiting for someone to be the first
person to to make that kind of move
Putin thinks time is on his side so he's
not willing to do it zinski also thinks
I think time is on his side so for that
reason neither of the leaders really at
this moment are willing to make those
kind of tough self-abnegating choices
which negotiations will involve oh and
Mark just mentioned president zalinski
what are his positions public publicly
but perhaps more importantly privately
on this issue of a
deal well uh as far as I understand it
his private position is pretty much the
same as his public position is that they
um uh they realize um that there's a
fatal um there's a
fatal Cascade that begins in your war
effort if you start to decide that you
are talking and once once you announce
that you know you actually
immediately basically pull the carpet in
terms of morale and in terms of you know
no one wants to be in a famously John
kery said no want to be the last man to
die for a mistake and that's the and
that's the the Colossal problem for for
for for zilinski in admitting any kind
of negotiation furthermore by the way
last October zilinski actually wrote
into law that negotiations with the
Putin regime was literally illegal so he
literally is not able to do that until
he changes his own law I it's kind of
strange kind of thing to write into law
but nonetheless I mean that zilinski did
it to Signal his resolve not one step
back but at the same time uh you see um
growing discontent uh or not discontent
but certainly like the return of
politics let's put it like that in Kiev
and by a gigantic irony the only thing
that is actually keeping zinski and the
main thing is keeping zalinski popular
and keeping Ukraine United is um Putin's
support
attacks you absent the Christmas and New
Year bombardment which was which has
been among the heaviest of of of the war
you would actually see actually very
rather serious uh uh fishes and debates
uh developing in in Ukrainian society
and I just spent three weeks in Kiev and
uh I spoke to lots of people for for you
know current and former zalinski uh
senior ministers and um and and advisers
and uh those who oppose him or CH you
know who would under normal
circumstances speak out prefer not to
because you know it's you know
P it's not the time to to do it now that
we're under attack but um there is
actually you know growing ground sell of
opinion that zalinski actually has
mismanaged the war and not that we
should like surrender put up our hands
and and hand over the territories but
certainly there some kind of uh there
some kind of um uh uh compromise has to
be reached with the Russians and if you
look as as Mark rightly said the
Ukrainian people's opinion it all
depends very much on on the question you
ask is because if you ask a slightly
different question and it was asked at
the beginning of December do you think
that some kind of compromise is
necessary uh uh um uh to end this war um
then 43% of ukrainians surveyed by um
well-respected K poer said yes and 46%
no so I mean you know clearly there's a
very large minority of ukrainians that
are are actually kind of willing to not
not only willing to do a deal or but but
but willing to publicly admit that a
deal needs to be done Mark last question
in his new year's address Putin didn't
really mention his war in Ukraine it
seems like he wants to distract or even
move on from the conflict when it comes
to those kinds of public speeches if
there were some kind of a deal we can
pretty much assume that regardless of
what it look like money would be pouring
into Ukraine from the West immediately
to help it rebuild we can not say the
same about the West reaction to Russia
would Putin be allowed to return to
activity as usual even if a peace deal
were secured well look there's no
question that we'd return to some kind
of status quo anti even if there was
some kind of not just a ceasefire but an
actual peace deal probably we would see
some kind of sanctions relief as a
necessary part of that deal but even so
I mean essentially we're entering in a
future in which at least as long as
Putin is in the Kremlin there will be
continued controls over the export of
Technology over investment into Russia
and so forth I mean we we are heading
back into a Cold War era in that respect
so you know again it won't just simply
be a sort of kumb by Our Moment where we
all just sort of pretend that that this
ghastly war never happened but that said
I think from from Putin's point of view
he is in a position in which actually he
is constrained I think more by his own
sense of his historic Destiny his place
in in in sort of the basically the
pantheon of Russian statebuilding
Heroes rather than pressure from below
it is not actually as if most Russians
are sitting there saying and go go back
to the example that Owen gave that aiva
must be ours they don't want to lose but
that's you know but not wanting to be
defeated is different from actually
having some kind of clear objectives if
Putin were able to negotiate something
that looked like a piece and looked like
a piece from his point of view with
honor and remember he controls the media
so he has considerable freedom to spin
whatever happens as as some kind of
honorable success if he can do that then
I think the Russian people will will be
quite accepting of that but as I say I
think I'm not I think Putin himself in
this respect is is the constraint he
will know that it won't really be a
victory and I think he may well not feel
that that is either politically survival
for him or the Legacy that he wants to
go down in
history Owen and Mark thanks so much for
joining spectator
[Music]
TV